clayton kershaw on the year
obviously other than colorado he has
been lights out he's working on a
scoreless streak
and the one thing he's also doing is
throwing his slider awfully well he's
throwing a lot of breaking balls
the fastball actually works almost matt
as a show pitch now he's been on fire
[Music]
there's a ball sharply hit the third it
bounced from turner to seeger the throw
to first however not in time in san
diego puts its lead off hitter reward to
start the ball game three balls and a
strike
and grisham sends a ball to deep right
center field on the run as bets on the
track he makes the catch
ricky betts just picked up clayton
kershaw hanging slider
and mookie one of the best takes a
direct route
and a steady shower of bluebirds come
out to greet
former dodger manny machado
machado's jam sends a ball out to
shallow left that'll drop in tatteez
trying to get back to the bag an errant
throw that's
backed up by rios and the padres have
runners hit first and second with one
away
on the ground to shortstop seeger gets
one himself and he's got plenty of time
to do it by himself the double play
it is you darvish on the mound off to a
great start this year the 34 year old
four-time all-star
one of the flashy winter pickups
executed by padres general manager aj
preller
and he has paid early dividends so far
in san diego
ricky betts with a shot into the corner
that's on his way and a second with a
lead off double
that is his first career hit believe it
or not against you darvish snapping a no
for six bets advancing to third
max muncie now
[Applause]
and muncie lines up gap her into right
field
that's gonna bring in bets and the
dodgers crack the scoreboard
early in game two tonight muncie has a
sweet zone and it's right there
when he changed his game and changed his
career
trajectory it was he did not miss one
middle in pitch period clayton kershaw
has a one-nothing lead going back to
work in the top of the second inning
facing will myers
just as much offense as we saw the
entire afternoon on
saturday when kershaw and darvish met
will myers lifts off
to deep left and gone and just like that
it's tied at one a piece
if you were to identify one hitter
in this padres that
really didn't like facing kershaw the
most
it would be will myers that is rare
success
against a guy that has had his number
for years
you darvish back to work on aj pollock
leading things off for relay
got him with a slider good pitch
first of the game for darvish right
fielder number 62.
the hitter has no chance against a pitch
like this when he's seeing fastball
two out runner aboard 3-2 and he got him
with the breaking goal
back to tatis now with one gun fernando
reached on what was scored as an
error in the first swinging at the first
pitch and it's 2-1
san diego oh man he kept both hands on
the bed on that swing
and tatis did not miss that pitch right
down and in and i'm telling you that's
the easiest way for him
to stay connected to solo homers
by the way the first two homers allowed
by clayton kershaw all year
what do you think kershaw thought about
that pitch yeah knew it
he knew every pitcher knows one out one
on in a two to one game there's
justin turner now and turner's locked up
he must have been guessing spin there
and took a look at a 96 mile an hour
fastball to cut the blade in half and he
knew it
two on two out to now it's edwin rios
got him changing the game plan after
that rocky first
seven in a row retired right now by
kershaw as he works with two outs
tati's coming up in the air to deep left
field down the line towards the corner
it is
gone home run fernando's gone deep again
in l.a
homer's in back-to-back plate
appearances against the three-time
cy young award winner yeah and you can
showboat it around the pillows
well we told you the homer he hit in the
third was the hardest
exit velo home run he'd ever hit
he did it one better with this swing
116 miles an hour off the bat
lead off hitter on base for the top of
the order now and mookie betts has been
on base twice
he did come back with a fastball and
bench lines it into left was that a
catch by tommy faber did he trap it he's
up indicating that it was trapped they
throw to first
and double off kershaw
oh yeah he caught that ball he made the
call it was an impossible read
for clayton kershaw and of course he
gets in no man's land right about here
and fam makes a great play
and an easy double play review it and it
was an easier double play than what was
anticipated
[Applause]
seeger pops it up and there's tatis to
make the play an inning that started
with the clayton kershaw base hit
ends with a fizzle there's the 3-2 pitch
to turner on its way
10th pitch of the at-bat on its way got
him
back up slider that locked up turner he
was not
looking inside corner sometimes a pitch
like that you'll look
later and go i'm going to use that down
the road against
a particular player i'm on a front door
of the slider max muncie now he's had a
good night an rbi single in a walk the
next one two to muncie
got him that slider is snappy tonight
the next one two from darvish there it
is oh
man the dodgers will pinch hit he's in a
big spot here
representing the go-ahead run
bob seeger song nine tonight for you
darvish
carratini was fired up there yeah watch
this right here
fastball we want to get betts too he's
saying
first pitch to mookie is lined to third
machado makes the play
and the fire is extinguished and la
stays quiet
another good one between these two
rivals still 3-1
san diego
it didn't it didn't work tommy pham with
his sharply struck single back up the
middle that's going to wrap myers around
to score an rbi
single for tommy pham and it's a four to
one
san diego leads he's getting out of the
dodgers control here pretty quickly
kirk to sally five in a row
relay not in time for the double play
cronenworth scores five to one
san diego so a bonus played appearance
for fernando tatis junior runners at
second and third with sugan
sharply hit the shortstop seeger
backhands throw to first is not in time
they come home on the trailing runner
and they get profar
but a sixth run does cross the plate rbi
credited to tatis pinch hitter here with
two gun dj
peters will make his first ever big
league played appearance
and on the first pitch another try for
machado
another flip of a throw and that'll wrap
her up tonight
san diego padres have taken two in a row
to start
this series a 6-1 win this evening